what i want to do in this video is graph
a classic exponential function and then
graph a related logarithmic function and
see how the two are related visually and
the two things i'm going to graph
are the y is equal to 2 to the x power
and
y is equal to the log
base 2 of x i encourage you to pause the
video make a table for each of them and
try to graph them on the same graph
paper and see how they are related and
if you see how they're related think
about why they are related that way
so let's first start with y equals 2 to
the x power so i'll make a little table
here different x values and the
corresponding y values
so
x and y we could start with negative 2
negative 1 0 1 2 3.
so in each case y is going to be 2
raised to this power so 2 to the
negative 2 power
is going to be 1 4
two to the negative one power is one
half two to the zero power is one two to
the first power is two two to the second
power is four two to the third power is
eight so let's graph that so two to the
third power is
eight
two to the fourth
two to the
two to the four sorry two to the two to
the third power is eight two to the
second power
is
four
two to the first power is 2
2 to the 0th power is 1. 2 to the
negative 1 power is one-half
2 to the negative 2 power is one-fourth
we'll get even a 2 to the negative third
power is going to be 1 8 so it's going
to look something like this so the graph
is going to look it's going to look
something
it's going to look something like
this right over here
and it's kind of your classic sometimes
this will be called your exponential
hockey stick because it kind of looks
like a hockey stick where it's just it
just kind of starts kind of slow and
just bam shoots straight up and notice
as we go to the left as x becomes more
and more and more negative our value
approaches zero but never quite gets
there if we have 2 to the negative 1
millionth power it's going to be a very
very small number very very close to 0
but it's not going to be quite zero so
it's going to we're going to have a
horizontal asymptote at x or at y is
equal to 0 or the x-axis is a horizontal
asymptote
fair enough
now let's graph now let's graph y is
equal to log base 2 of x and before i
graph that let's just think about
another way of representing it this
literally says for any x
what power what exponent y would if i
raised 2 to that would give me x so this
is an equivalent statement
as saying 2 to the y power is equal to x
and if you notice what we've done here
between these two things you're
essentially just switching the x's and
y's here's 2 to the x power is equal to
y here's 2 to the y power is equal to x
so really this and this you've swapped
the x's and the y's so you've swapped
the x's and the y's and what we will see
is
that we can essentially swap these two
columns so x and y
so let me just do 1
one half
one
one two
four
and eight
two
four and eight
so here now we're saying if x is one
fourth if x is one fourth what power do
we have to raise two to
to get to one fourth we have to raise it
to the negative two power
two to the negative one power is equal
to one half two to the zero power is
equal to one two to the first power is
equal to two two to the second power is
equal to four two to the third power is
equal to eight notice all we did
is we essentially swapped these two
columns and so let's graph this when x
is equal to one fourth y is equal to
negative 2.
when x is one-half y is equal to
negative 1
y is equal to negative 1. when x is 1 y
is 0.
when x is 2
y is
1.
when x is 4
y is 2. when x is 8 y is 3.
so it's going to look like this
so notice i think you might already be
seeing a pattern right over here
these two graphs are essentially the
reflections of each other and what would
you have to reflect about to get these
two
well you'd have to reflect about y is
equal to x so if you swap the x's and
the y's
so another way to think about if you
swap the axis you would get the other
graph which is essentially what we're
essentially what we're doing notice it's
a metric about that line and that's
because these are essentially the
inverse functions of each other one way
to think about it is we swapped we
swapped the x's and y's just as this as
a as as x becomes more and more and more
and more negative you see y approaching
zero here you see as y is becoming more
and more negative as y is approaching is
getting more and more negative x is
approaching zero or you could say as x
approaches zero y becomes more and more
and more negative so the whole point of
this is just to give you an appreciation
for the relationship between an
exponential function and a logarithmic
function they're essentially inverses of
each other and you see that in their
graphs they're reflections of each other
about the line
y is equal to x